THE WHITE HOUSE TO DO EXACTLY
THAT.
NEIL: ALL RIGHT, WHAT THEY ARE
SAYING IS THE RANKING MINORITY
MEMBER CERTAINLY ON THE HOUSE
WAYS AND MEANS COMMITTEE THE GUY
THAT CAME UP WITH THE TAX CUTS
THAT WE GOT IS THIS NOTION THAT
IF WE GET HEAVY HEAVY DEPENDENCY
FROM CHINA ON THE DRUGS AND ON
RELATED SUPPLIES, THAT WE REALLY
DEPEND ON, 70% OF THEM ARE
COMING FROM THAT NECK OF THE
WOODS SO THE ADMINISTRATION
KICKING AROUND THE IDEA AT LEAST
LARRY KUDLOW RAISED THAT MAYBE,
WE ENTICE THOSE COMPANIES BACK
FOR THAT REGION AND CUT THEIR
TAX RATES IN HALF, ALREADY
PRETTY LOW RIGHT NOW, TO
INCENTIVIZE THEM BACK TO OUR
SHORES.
LET’S GET THE READ ON ALL OF
THIS , LABOR SECRETARY JOINING
US OUT OF WASHINGTON D.C.
SECRETARY VERY GOOD TO HAVE YOU.
IS THAT BEING GIVEN SERIOUS
CONSIDERATION, SIR?
>> I THINK THAT YES OUR
DEPENDENCY ON OTHER NATIONS
PARTICULARLY CHINA IS SOMETHING
THAT IS GETTING A CAREFUL LOOK
AS WE EXAMINE WHAT OUR ECONOMIC
FUTURE IS GOING TO LOOK LIKE AS
WE PULL OUT OF THIS
CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC, AND
EARLIER THIS WEEK, NEIL AS YOU
KNOW THE PRESIDENT TOOK ACTION
TO PREVENT FEDERAL RETIREE,
FUNDS FROM BEING INVESTED IN
CHINESE COMPANIES INCLUDING
CHINESE MANUFACTURES AND THAT
WAS NOT IN OUR NATIONAL SECURITY
INTEREST, IT WASN’T IN THE
INTEREST OF THOSE RETIREES
SOME OF WHOM ARE MILITARY
BECAUSE OF SOME RISKS THAT ARE
PRESENTED BY THIS CHINESE
COMPANY.
THAT’S JUST ONE EXAMPLE.
HOW ABOUT REASSURE PRAISE ALL
THAT I THINK WILL HAPPEN ABOUT
OUR DEPENDENCE ON OTHER
COUNTRIES PARTICULARLY CHINA.
NEIL: YOU KNOW, THE REACTION TO
CUTTING THE CORPORATE TAX RATE
ALREADY PRETTY LOW IN HALF FOR
SOME OF THESE COMPANIES, I
DON’T KNOW HOW YOU SORT THAT OUT
, SECRETARY, FOR THOSE
COMPANIES THAT ARE
GOING TO LOOK OVER AND SAY WELL
WHY IS THEIR RATE HALF
MINOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE’S
REACTION, WHEN A LOT OF THEM ARE
WANTING MORE OF THESE $1,200
CHECKS, DO YOU HAVE ANY VISION
ON EITHER?
>> MY POSITION IS THAT
GENERALLY, WE ARE REOPENING, AS
YOU JUST EMPHASIZED A MOMENT
AGO ITS BEEN AN EXTRAORDINARILY
DIFFICULT TIME FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, SO MANY LIVES LOST, SO
MANY FAMILIES DISRUPTED, AND SO
MANY PEOPLE OUT OF WORK BUT
WE’RE NOT PULLING OUT OF THAT
AND WE NEED TO TAKE A LOOK AT
ADDITIONAL MEASURES TO SUSTAIN
AMERICAN MANUFACTURING, THAT HAS
BEEN AN  EMPHASIS OF THIS
PRESIDENT FROM THE DAY HE
BEGAN RUNNING IT WAS MORE THAN
ANYTHING ELSE THAT PROMPTED THE
PRESIDENT TO RUN.
U.S.  MCA HAS BEEN ONE OF HIS
GREAT ACHIEVEMENTS AND THAT WAS
ABOUT SAVING AMERICAN
MANUFACTURING, SAVING AMERICAN
JOBS, AND I THINK CONTINUED
FOCUS ON THAT MAKES SENSE.
IN TERMS OF OTHER MEASURES,
LET’S SEE WHAT WE NEED.
CONGRESS, THE PRESIDENT ACTED SO
QUICKLY IN MARCH.
THERE’S BEEN A LOT OF STIMULUS
IN THERE, AND THE FOCUS NOW FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE IS ON THE
REOPENING.
NEIL: YOU’RE THE LABOR SECRETARY
OF THE UNITED STATES.
YOU HAVE MORE THAN ANYONE WITH
THE JOB LOSSES THAT HAVE PILED
UP AND THOSE FILING FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS,
SECRETARY, WE’RE NOW IN THE LAST
EIGHT WEEKS 36.5 MILLION
AMERICANS HAVE FILED FOR SUCH
BENEFIT FEARS THAT THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE COULD JUMP
UP TO 20% EVEN TEST THE ALL-TIME
HIGH OF CLOSE TO 25% DURING THE
GREAT DEPRESSION.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF HOW BAD
THIS GETS?
>> LET ME TAKE ISSUE WITH ONE
PHRASE THAT YOU’VE USED, NEIL
WHICH IS JOB LOSSES.
THERE ARE TENS OF MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS THAT HAVE BEEN PUT OUT
OF WORK AND IT’S GREAT HARDSHIP
FOR THEM, BUT MANY OF THOSE JOBS
ARE NOT LOST YET, AND I’VE SEEN
THREE DIFFERENT SURVEYS OVER THE
LAST WEEK SHOWING THAT ABOUT
90% OF AMERICANS ON UNEMPLOYMENT
THINK IT’S TEMPORARY, THINK THEY
ARE GOING BACK TO THOSE JOBS.
WHAT WE WANT TO DO NOW IS GET
THEM BACK THERE, SAFELY.
THE LONGER THE REOPENING TAKES I
THINK THE HARDER THAT GETS, BUT
THIS IS A REALLY UNUSUAL
ECONOMIC CIRCUMSTANCE WE’RE IN
AND IT DID NOT RESULT FROM
PROBLEMS IN THE UNDERLYING
FUNDAMENTALS AS , FOR EXAMPLE,
THE GREAT DEPRESSION.
SO I THINK ANALOGIES THERE ARE
OF LIMITED VALUE.
WHAT WE HAVE IS A --
NEIL: LET ME GIVE YOU A CURRENT
ONE IF YOU DON’T MIND, SIR AND
THAT IS WHAT’S HAPPENING NOW,
WITH THE TENSIONS BETWEEN
OURSELVES AND THE CHINESE AND
THE PRESIDENT IS OBVIOUSLY VERY
CONCERNED THEY WERE NOT BEING
LEVEL WITH HIM WHEN TALKING
ABOUT THE CORONAVIRUS, OBVIOUSLY
TALKS ABOUT, YOU KNOW, THE
SHIELDING OUR INVESTMENTS IN
CHINESE-RELATED FIRMS.
I GET THAT BUT IT SEEMS TO ME
AND YOUR CLOSER READ THAN I’LL
EVER BE THAT THAT CHINA DEAL
THAT TRADE DEAL IS ALL BUT SMOKE
RIGHT NOW.
DO YOU HAVE ANY CONCERN THAT THE
JOBS AND
THE  BANG FOR THE BUCK WE WERE
HOPING TO GET FOR THE TRADE DEAL
BECAUSE WE TRUSTED THE CHINESE
WOULD MAKE GOOD ON THOSE
COMMITMENTS NOW IS IN
DOUBT BECAUSE WE ALREADY KNOW
THEY WEREN’T ON THE UP AND UP
ABOUT THIS VIRUS.
>> WELL, WE’LL NEED THEM TO
ABIDE BY THEIR COMMITMENTS,
OBVIOUSLY, AND I THINK THAT
ASSUMES GREATER IMPORTANCE NOT
LESS, BECAUSE OF OTHER MISS
GIVINGS THAT THEY’VE CAUSED FROM
HOW THEY HANDLED THE VIRUS, BUT
I THINK AS WE LOOK FORWARD AGAIN
, MILLIONS OF AMERICANS OUT
OF WORK, WHAT WE’RE FOCUSED ON
IS MAKING THAT TEMPORARY BY
SAFELY REOPENING THE ECONOMY
RIGHT NOW, PUTTING PEOPLE BACK
TO WORK, AND AS WE REOPEN,
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WE’RE ALREADY
SEEING THAT.
THIS HAS BEEN SO FLUID, NEIL,
AND WE’RE FINALLY SEEING PEOPLE
GETTING BACK TO WORK.
IT’S A GOOD SIGN.
NEIL: SIR, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.